tonight I want to talk about something
that you guys have been texting and
commenting about I have two children so
I'd say I'm pretty good at getting
pregnant but a lot of you out there are
trying and struggling so I wanted to
talk about this tonight tonight's topic
is the worst things about trying to get
pregnant if it was just about like
having sex we would not have an episode
about this so first it gets way too
clinical when most people think of
conceiving a child their thought is like
oh you get married and you go on a
honeymoon and you just make one and
that's not how it happens a lot of the
time for a lot of couples you want your
child to be conceived in this natural
environment of like warmth and love and
happiness and when you're charting
ovulation and you're like literally
using a calendar to figure out the best
day to make a baby it takes a lot of the
romance out of it which is discouraging
especially if it does not work out for
you the first couple of months it turns
into this like paying on a lot of sticks
scheduling sex monitoring your diet
monitoring your partner's diet having to
wait which is such an annoying part of
it because that's the way you know if
that whole month was a success or a
waste so while I know it can get into
this cycle of like non romance kind of
clinical trying to have as much fun with
it as you possibly can and just make the
most of the situation at hand and at
least you're getting some you know like
you're having sex so next the jealousy I
have the most insane baby fever right
now and I mean insane because now is not
a reasonable time for me to have a child
I have two beautiful children already
and it just so happens that most of my
friends are pregnant and they're all
posting pictures of their cribs that
they're sending up in their nursery and
their bump progress photos and their
gender reveal and all that [ __ ] and I'm
just like thank you what we all need to
realize is that this person is not
taking anything away from you it's not
like their child is the child that you
could have had so while the jealousy is
real don't try to steal it cuz I know
they smell really nice I'm like you
might be tempted but I've thought this
through and it's just
gonna work you don't want to live your
life on the run as good as their heads
smell next you become hyper aware of
your body every little blip feels like
something and you become this like
hypochondriac of sorts like for me I
would have like a little gas bubble and
be like it's like no I don't even know
if I'm pregnant
it's gas and it doesn't help that
pregnancy symptoms are the same as
period symptoms because you're bloated
you're moody you know you have a little
bit of crimping all that stuff like is
either period or baby but there's just
no way of knowing which one it is so you
end up constantly convincing yourself
that you're pregnant but I've had
friends tell me I'm pregnant I'm I'm
absolutely pregnant I pushed my boob a
bunch of times and it hurt and I'm like
no you just you pushed your boom until
it hurt I feel like there's got to be a
better solution for this like why don't
our belly buttons just like pop out or
something like what is that it's like a
turkey thermometer like oh my switch
flipped there we go
so next April Fool's I don't know who
started this trend of just an
announcement we're expecting if it's
like a piece of food on an ultrasound
that's not funny
first of all it's so overdone it's so
stupid
and it's very insensitive and it really
bums people out who are trying to
conceive and are unable to so if you're
thinking about doing a pregnancy
announced in April Fool's it's been done
there are way better ideas you come see
me later I will give you like ten gold
April Fool's jokes that's all you need
to know
and last unsolicited advice I don't know
what it is about people who encounter
someone who's trying and they decide to
just blurt out all the stupid [ __ ] but
I've heard the weirdest stuff when it
comes to trying to conceive like oh you
gotta do it every day oh just do it
every day okay that's fine if you're
trying for like two weeks but have you
tried doing it every day for a [ __ ]
year do you know how sore you would be
[Music]
that's just not possible the best piece
of advice is when you stop trying is
when it's gonna happen like what do you
mean by stop trying you mean when you
stop having
I don't know if you didn't take human
development in school or you can't just
stop having sex and then magically get
pregnant it's not how it works and I'm
realizing that I'm a total hypocrite
like making a whole video giving advice
I'm just trying to help you through it
as a person who's been through it I'm
just trying to create a safe space for
it when you look into your child dies
you're not going to remember like the
sticks you peed on or the blood tests
you took or the doctor's visits you had
to do and like whatever process it took
whether it was conceiving or IVF or
adoption none of that matters and
however it happens I hope it does happen
for you and what it does it's gonna be
everything so to all of you out there
who are trying may your conception be
fruitful like this wine of grapes that's
like I got for today I'm Hannah your
friendly neighborhood wine mom and if
there's a topic you want me to talk
about in a future episode or any
experience you have with trying to
conceive leave it in the comments or you
can always text me I don't always
respond but I read every single one I
love to hear what you guys want me to
talk about and I love hearing your
personal stories and in the meantime I'm
gonna go on Facebook and look at all my
friends pictures of their newborns to
feel my baby fever till next time oh my
god there's old
oh my god